[Música]
no hay clases las escuelas están
cerradas la gente está sufriendo mucho
mucho una devastadoras inundaciones
azotaron Nigeria en octubre dejando un
saldo al menos 600 muertos y más de un
millón de desplazados en las comunidades
situadas a lo largo de los ríos níger y
benuee el nivel de las aguas alcanzó un
récord de 13 metros en el estado de
bielsa al menos 700.000 personas han
sido desplazadas allí vive nuestra
observadora liefa obot
ya hemos tenido inundaciones en el
pasado en diferentes ocasiones
pero esta inundación de 2022 supera todo
lo que hemos visto porque está matando
gente
es cada vez peor el agua sigue subiendo
la gente estaba durmiendo y cuando se
despertó el agua ya estaba en sus casas
cerca del 80% de las casas de humanidad
se inundaron
las inundaciones han cortado las
carreteras hacia los estados fronterizos
Así que somos más o menos como una isla
en el estado no se puede viajar
para llegar a otras comunidades hay que
ir en barco o en Canoa en esa época hoy
por la información que me ha llegado la
carretera del otro lado está cubierta de
aguas muchos agricultores han perdido
sus cosechas productos o alimentos que
tenían para vender
tierra por ningún lado
desde aquí por 200 kilómetros no se
puede ver Tierra y todo esto eran
tierras de cultivo
gente se está muriendo la gente está
sufriendo para la gente es muy difícil
poder alimentarse
las autoridades nigerianas afirman que
las lluvias
récord son la causa de las inundaciones
pero muchos analistas han señalado otros
criterios o como un embalse en el vecino
país de Camerún
si nos fijamos en el origen de La
Represa de Camerún fue en 1977 cuando se
tomó la decisión de construirla se
llamaba La Represa del acto
si se desborda y tienen que liberar agua
por supuesto esa agua siempre acabará en
Nigeria Nigeria también prometió tener
su propia Represa para recibir agua en
caso de que fuera liberada de La Represa
del acto pero lamentablemente la
construcción de esta Represa ha sido
lenta y no ha sido terminada todavía
muchas personas han criticado a Camerún
por liberar el agua
pero creo que si no hubiera habido
puntos débiles como la falta de drenaje
o la mala plani por parte de Nigeria
las inundaciones Podrían haber sido
menos extremas si no queremos tener
estas inundaciones el año que viene Creo
que ya es hora de que construyamos
nuestra propia Represa
[Música]
en la reacción de los observadores
tenemos muy a menudo estos tres vídeos
que tienen dos puntos en común el
primero que acusan a Ucrania de hacer
montaje para conmocionar la opinión
pública en la guerra contra Rusia el
segundo es que sonó todo noticias falsas
con imágenes sacadas de contexto ya les
mostramos Por qué en el primer ejemplo
directores de cine supuestamente filman
un montaje sobre la supuestas
atrocidades de las tropas rusas en la
ciudad de costomel este video fue
publicado en una cuenta de tiktok el
pasado mes de agosto su autor especifica
en los comentarios
es un documental región de Héroes sobre
los sucesos de hucha irping y gostomel
[Música]
efectivamente el 24 de noviembre se
estrenará una película llamada región de
Héroes que narra la vida cotidiana de
los habitantes de la región de kiev bajo
ocupación rusa en la página de Instagram
de la productora se puede ver los mismos
elementos del set que en el video así
que no se trata de un montaje para los
medios de comunicación sino del rodaje
de una película
Esta es otra acusación de montaje que
muestra la supuesta huida de los
ucranianos Incluso se dice que el actor
estadounidense sean penn y su equipo de
producción la estarían dirigiendo pero
de nuevo esto es falso con una simple
búsqueda invertida de imágenes el video
se puede encontrar en YouTube en 2013 la
escena se rodó para la película invasion
Planet Earth en las calles de Birmingham
en Inglaterra Incluso se puede encontrar
en fragmento de este rodaje en el
tráiler de la película
[Música]
Así que es otra noticia falsa por último
terminamos con este vídeo
este hombre es presentado como un
reservista ucraniano que actuaba para
las cámaras occidentales lo encontramos
en tiktok y lo llamamos
soy Peter shere King soy un actor cómico
ucraniano
música este video es un fragmento de un
clip de la excelente cantante ucraniana
Ana canina
la canción se llama canción de cuna
es una canción sobre la guerra que está
teniendo lugar en Ucrania el director me
dijo quiero que me muestres el dolor y
no es solo el dolor de un golpe
Muéstrame el dolor de la guerra
la pena de la Guerra el horror de la
guerra muéstralo todo en este grito
empezaron a llamarme para decirme que
este vídeo está siendo utilizado como
información falsa
puedo decirles que no derrotarán a los
ucranianos con sus noticias falsas ni
con sus bombardeos
Si tiene alguna duda sobre un vídeo no
duden enviarnos a nuestra cuenta de
Twitter
@infoints france24 nuestros equipos lo
van a realizar por ustedes
[Música]
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
observadores por esta semana como
siempre nuestros contactos están en su
pantalla si quieren contactar a nuestro
equipo envíenos sus vídeos y fotos para
cubrir juntos la actualidad
internacional en imágenes aficionadas
Hasta pronto